oh my god
where did you come from
i grew up in fort lauderdale but now my
dad lives oh my god i love family so i
go there sometimes he marries
[Music]
[Laughter]
drops of my blood
what what
holy [ __ ] is he confirmed that's gotta
be mepisto no way no way oh my god yo
it's gotta be it's gotta be who else is
gonna make a deal that's the only devil
i know
holy [ __ ]
i made a pact with a demon that i cannot
discuss
otherwise he said he would reap my soul
and the souls of all i love which
honestly is so dramatic and i hate drama
that is mephisto that sounds a lot like
mephisto can't lie cannot even lie my
goodness
what did you do madison he is confirmed
this is babisto i'm not crazy this time
i'm not crazy now you are not crazy
that's a demon that's a debate it may
have been crazy past times not this time
not this time
wait wait
oh my god
oh my god oh my god that is him
i don't care what you call him
that's hi my name is jake name tag
they're making fun of me i swear to god
they're targeting you
i feel targeted i i feel seen i feel
seen i feel see
and targeted
welcome back to new rock stars memphisto
is confirmed in the mcu he's been
confirmed for the sixth time if you ask
me but this time it counts it counts
this is our clearest confirmation yet
and she-hulk episode four introduces
madison with a why but not where you
think
she gets sent to this fiery hell
dimension where a talking goat named
jake saves her from a lava pit in
exchange for her soul
holy
shield hulk this is inside marvel new
rockstar's official after show for
she-hulk i'm eric voss with me is mt hey
mt
hey what's going on homie
i hope to goddess of a fist though oh i
hope so too it's such a shame that jess
is on vacation this week i wish she was
here for this you just
we need you here to help us or at least
to talk some sense to us but while jess
is out this week she did pre-shoot her
easter egg breakdown for episode four so
it's still going to come out later today
stick around for it because i'm sure she
has some thoughts on the pistol or
whether or not
whether or not we're crazy but uh yeah
what a fun episode that that digs into
the deeper lore of the mcu of course but
also just explores how awful it is to
swipe date in los angeles oh my god it's
quite terrible her her first dates were
uh pretty pretty awful a lot of people
yeah there's uh yeah it's it's never a
fun time i think well in this episode we
start with a magician named donnie blaze
it's not johnny blaze it's donnie blaze
there was a joke there right i mean come
on we're making johnny blaze rapper and
silly that had to be intentional he does
a show at the mystic castle and if you
live in the los angeles area you know
this is a parody of the los angeles
based magic castle theater and you know
you see this get made fun of a lot
actually the mcu has already made fun of
this with like jimmy wu doing doing
close-up magic right like i feel like he
would take classes at this place
and it seems like tv writers and movie
writers love to make fun of the magic
castle but the truth is
it is the coolest freaking thing to do
if you live in l.a because
you can't just walk up and go you have
to know someone uh and i have like one
or two friends who uh who were members
it's a private club and you have to get
them uh to get you on the list you have
to dress up nice to go and i believe
they shot the interior of this magic
theater that it might actually be the
interior of the main stage of the magic
castle uh and which is why it's just
kind of like frustrating for me to see
it like half empty
every show at the magic castle is full
it is like the hottest ticket in town
you cannot go and it's not a cheesy
thing when you go in you are like
transporting you're like you know what
it's easy to make fun of magicians but
this place is dope like it's really fun
and like the tricks that donnie blaise
were doing i think you people would be
like yeah all right they'd be into it
like it's like it's okay we can make fun
of magicians but like half of the people
who work in the writer's room in
she-hulk started doing ucb improv
classes and nothing's a bigger cult in
los angeles in the theater that's just
down the other side of franklin avenue
called ucb so like yeah make fun of it
all you want but the reason you have the
work you have right now is by being part
of a different cult in los angeles all
right so shut your mouth
all sorts of cults in la
i mean just across the street from ucb
is the scientology celebrity center
which is another freaking literal castle
on franklin and like
i believe the scientologists own the
block where ucb pays rent to so it's
like no all of our hands are dirty in
los angeles no one is superior all right
so uh
the magic castle is the most wholesome
purest thing that's on franklin in los
angeles all right so go easy on the poor
magicians they're losers but they put on
a great show and a great restaurant
there too i i love the magic castle i
will go to the great lawyers for other
majorities
yes they do apparently apparently so we
meet my favorite mcu phase four
characters since i get the hardness
madison with two ends in hawaii
we must protect her at all costs i love
madison i hope she's okay after her
right i hope she's broken i know i know
and she did start to talk about that
contract and i don't know i mean
whatever i mean i i feel like her if her
soul gets claimed by mephisto what what
an honor what an honor right seriously
what an honor for you mephisto
so she participates and and what's so
fun about this character is like
absolutely if you go to the magic castle
you're going to see like eight different
madisons with the why not where you
think walking around they're gonna be
there with their cocktails spilling it
all over volunteering to go up on stage
is exactly the experience that you'll
see
the only difference is it would be
packed there would be at least 20 other
madisons walking around it's just all
madison's it's all madison it's all
madisons and guys who are trying to be
like maybe this will impress madison and
then madison's like i'm not that
impressed but good on you
for taking these magic classes so donnie
sends madison through a clearly stolen
sling rings portal uh and she goes to
this hellis dimension comes out the
other side with a bloody heart in her
hand lands at comartaj where she tells
wong that she made a deal with this
demonic talking goat and then she spoils
one of the best episodes of the sopranos
long-term parking for a second for a
second i thought they were just
parodying like camera taj and doing a
soprano style intro because that music
slaps i was like
are we saying are we saying gong is a
tony soprano of kamartaj if so can that
just be the case can we do like is is
all of the mcu wong's dream from the
beginning of season five of the sopranos
where he has like this crazy david lynch
style dream sequence with annette
benning showing up playing herself like
couldn't that be what the mcu is just
wong's fever dream where he's been like
injured somewhere and he's like yeah i
get to imagine myself as a sorcerer
supreme and then he's like he's still on
the mountain on wondergourmouth he's
just knocked out
can can all the mcu end with just like
wong in a restaurant and then it just
blacks out on wong and that's the end of
the mcu and you don't really know what
happened
god i hope so
wong is my tony soprano i think at the
end of the day okay i mean if you think
like the the death of phil leotardo in
the ending of season whatever of of the
sopranos is similar to the illuminati
being killed off right that if anything
was a godfather-style slain where
people's heads were being imploded i
think this is all connecting mt i think
we we discovered
there's too many coincidences a new
galaxy brain theory here uh anyway it's
all sopranos
mcc problems
yes okay so jen tells her dad that she
never reported that wrecking crew
attacked the police which i'm sure is
going to come back to haunt her but she
sets up a dating profile uh and then
wong shows up telling jen that donnie
blaze was a student of the mystic arts
but only for a week until he was kicked
out for summoning kegs to his frat
brothers so they decide to sue donnie
blaze to stop him from using real magic
but donnie and the theater owner this a
delightful uh charming man named
cornelius p willows blows them off
he's great and then jen goes on a date
with a douche named allen who makes her
pick up the tab now i have to go on a
bit of a rant here again i know he can
talk about how i lived in la for 12
years and i probably sound a lot like
alan uh but i 12 years is a long time to
get to know a pretty long time and i can
attest i did spend before i met kelly i
spent quite a bit of time going on swipe
dates like this and yes this is very
true they suck and a lot of us are
douches who are very superficial and uh
we will just talk about ourselves the
whole time we get intimidated by women
who have successful careers and while i
just came from like a nowheresville in
in florida a lot of the people who moved
to la are these guys who spent like a
year and a half in new york or chicago
and act like they are experts on those
cities but like they couldn't cut it in
those cities and that's why they left
them
not all of them i mean look i met
someone from chicago and she's like my
favorite person in my life obviously but
she also grew up in chicago i think she
knows quite a bit about it
but there's and also i met some people
who spent like a year in chicago and
they're just delightful people but also
you meet some people who come from
chicago and new york and they kind of
suck it's a mixed bag here in l.a that's
just the truth but yes there are quite a
few allens there are allen's everywhere
on these dates uh and uh and i get that
that's meant to be satire but i'll just
say that every single allen that i know
they are very superficial and i just
don't know if they would call tatiana
mislania six that rang a little like
two peridic for me i'm like
i don't know i
i think more realistically they they
would be disasters they would just have
like panic attacks about her being a
lawyer and complaining that the reason
they can't get a tv writing job is
because of women like her that would be
the right idea
man i'm so sorry women that you have
date yes
oh for sure it's a dumpster fire oh
absolutely i'm not denying that at all
but i would just like
it's just on this show it's like tatiana
maslany's
beautiful i don't she's way more than a
six i i got us that dude was tripping
that dude was tripping like i don't know
they're living in some
reality delusion uh caused by doctor
strange and the other sorcerers to make
all the men see tatiana
is less attractive than she actually is
that's the only way that makes sense in
this universe so
um uh
okay
this is why we need chess here right now
i'm sorry because i think jess would say
like look you guys don't get it there
are you could be a complete 10 or 11 and
go on a date uh through tinder on la and
still be mistreated like this your
problem that's probably the truth of it
i just just mentioned it is terrible
like to be honest
not us empty now the two of us you and i
are perfect there's nothing wrong with
that
we're flawless we're flawless men
we're allies we're the good
i'm the only good man in the world so
come on come on over everybody that's
right that's right we're perfect
jessica's gonna get here next week and
be like you're both trash
she's gonna reach through her computer
screens and slap us because
she would not let us get away with this
not at all
no no we're going on a field day so
madison testifies against donnie blaze i
love they bring her in as a witness i
want to know what party she was at ahead
of time but absolutely i would have been
in that crowd going madison
i would love if it was the the zemo
party because it kind of looked like
this
yes
it was in the background
[Laughter]
and what i love about it is this is if
she lived in l.a right because she was
at the mystic castle which is an la
venue uh the courtroom is in la clearly
like a morning trial wherever this party
was it was like clearly no windows
24-hour rave where she's just like
drinking she's that drunk in the morning
which is like this is exactly the kind
of party that i would never go to but
like a part of me wishes i could be cool
enough to go to those you know right
same here i can't do loud noises i mean
i'm telling you if you live in la
joseph's on ivar and yucca i would park
there going to my improv theater which
is on hollywood it was not on franklin i
wasn't good enough to get into ucb on a
team well i did get on uct at one point
but i didn't last uh i was not funny or
cool enough but i was at another theater
and i would park over odd yucca to go to
my sunday morning sketch team rehearsals
at 10 a.m and i would walk by this crazy
looking place just called joseph's with
no windows but you can hear
and then madison's madisons would walk
out and be like
it's so bright and i'm like
what were you doing all night it's 10 am
go to church go to church and there was
a church uh church of scientology right
down the street and i'm sure the
scientology people were like come right
on our bus here we go
on the bus
on the bus
and that's that's the engine that
perpetuates hollywood everybody that's
that's how it works but so she
elaborates that uh j that uh donnie
blaze sent her into a fire land i love
that she calls it a fire land like it's
a world in mario brothers three um and
uh she uh she meets a talkie goat named
jake where she made a pact with him
she's not allowed to talk about the pact
or he'll reap her soul and the souls of
all she loved i mean this is this is
mephisto 100
wong has an interesting statement that
he makes where he warns that one man in
the mortal realm has the ability to
cause a ripple so great it reverberates
through every dimension and that ripple
through galaxies has the ability to
destroy all life through the known and
unknown universe just like kind of an
interesting thematic statement if you
compare it to people like wanda maximoff
or steven strange or even wong himself
that really one person can uh with the
power of the gods can break the universe
through break the multiverse as we know
it i think we call those people nexus
beings i think we would say really right
now the judge allows this case to move
forward but allows donnie to continue
practicing his livelihood in the
meantime so jen goes on uh she gets no
matches and i just love that joke
she has a notification says you've had
no matches which is amazing she creates
a new account as she-hulk uh she gets a
ton of matches immediately she dates a
guy named derek who's weightlifter
played by wwe wrestler david ortunga
that's fun to see him cameo there she
goes on a date with this guy named todd
played by john bass who has shown up as
a character actor in a couple different
things like he might be a familiar face
to you interesting guy he's a nerd who
seems really into jen he calls her a
specimen asks whether vibranium could
pierce her skin i think we'll talk about
him a bit more later interesting guy i
don't think he would i think he'd cast a
smaller no-name actor to play this role
if he wasn't going to be so important
but then she also meets arthur a hunky
doctor way too good to be true makes all
the right moves she takes them home
he says you want to split fries and
she's like yes let's get this to go you
never get french fries to go the steam
is gonna make them all soggy in a
takeout container have you ever tried to
reheat fries in a microwave or eat cold
fries when you get them home are you
kidding the nights get pretty cool in
los angeles you gotta wear a jacket
unless it's like you know fire season or
something like that those fries are
going to be disgusting when you get them
home i'm just saying insane they're
insane it's almost like they're not
going to eat the fries at all what are
they going to do
almost like it's not about the fries
clearly this guy has never had a
successful swipe date i think that's
what we just learned about that
so put the fries but the fries
i just i just i worship at the altar of
french fries and if the single fry gets
uneaten from that basket i feel like a
crime has been committed i think it's
what really i mean that's a good feeling
i would roll with that feeling because
that is true so donnie blaze does
another show where he summons a bird
that lays an egg and a gashes into a
goblin monster that grows and grows and
grows it turns into these bat goblin
things he opens a portal to the hell
dimension where even more goblins swarm
out wong cleans up this mess gets
she-hulk's help and then jen returns to
arthur where they head off to the
bedroom and he knocks the lamp you know
that's the old hoovering roger rabbit
joke where that's how you show a vfx
thing interacting with the real world to
make him look more photorealistic you
literally knock the lamp so i love that
little a little wink there that little
tip of the hat to that so the next
morning the news reports that titania's
uh legal charges have been dropped so
this whole story with titania just been
kind of unfolding on news reports in the
background since the opening episode i
think that's a factor of probably them
restructuring the season uh because it's
so weird that she's clearly such a major
threat but they just keep like reporting
her on news reports
anyway so arthur wakes up
arthur dude uh like he sees that jen's
reverted human form loses all interest
another example of like
i'm sorry if you woke up to tatiana
maslany i don't think you'd be
disappointed i don't care who you are
it's like
right yeah like i would be totally fine
i'd be like first of all who are you oh
you're she that's fine yeah it's totally
fine i can do but yeah i i that's the
best of both worlds really
which is part of the reason why i
suspect that like some of these guys
going on dates with her might have been
after something else like i don't know
uh anyway we'll talk about in a bit um
but jen gets served a lawsuit to stop
using the name she-hulk and by the way
this is actually this actor who plays
the guy who brings the paperwork is uh
one of her tinder dates that she swiped
on it's actually jessica gao's uh
partner her longtime partner who's also
an artist uh so this guy is a cameo he
was like the guy who had a cat uh with a
sailor hat on it and he had to match her
matching captain hat uh so this guy is
like a friend of the show obviously not
our show
he could be a friend of our show hey
let's just say he is let's just say
and then we get this awesome post credit
tag where wang and madison are watching
this is us while they plan to drink
cocktails uh including what sounds like
a white russian made of vodka in yak's
milk that's fun
we we need a spin off with these two and
it needs to have a soprano style intro
every episode like i need a wong solo
like wagon madison just do water madison
i i will totally pay extra for disney
plus for that i think what we need is
like an episode of agatha coven of chaos
which was going to act at the house of
harkness and then like juan de vision
each episode should be its own kind of
like tv homage and we need to have at
least one episode where it's just a
sopranos parody with agatha
and we need madison playing the adriana
roll we need wong playing the tony
soprano roll and we need agatha to play
in the carm role right let's get this
man in the writings room right now like
regular let's see
right now come on man i need to see that
yesterday i think we need to dreamcast
the rest of the cast like who would be
chris multicente in this universe maybe
uh maybe evan
uh
i've never seen the surprise
[Laughter]
and see we need to we need to start a
viewing party with you
for me i was like come on madison why i
was gonna get you about eventually
all right before we dive in mt what's
going on with uh with the merch world yo
guys be sure to check out new
rockstarsmerch.com where you can grab
our newest latest obsession shirt lady
justice inspired by the she-hulk series
this shirt is limited edition and will
be gone faster than donnie blaze's
audience because that was pretty damn
fast so be sure to grab one when you can
and when you purchase the latest
succession church you unlock the ability
to get a custom shout out that will
appear right here on inside marvel it's
pretty dope but eric our first question
for today is
was mephisto the man himself just
confirmed to be mcu canon
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes we are
so in the past you all know that this
channel has been accused of making
mapisto mountains out of red mole hills
during wonderland i did point to any
reference to devil's demons and horned
animal skulls and shouted the best don't
convert but here's the deal i don't even
think i ever said mephisto confirmed
until it became a meme many other
channels made us look a bit silly by
widening their nets to any reference to
the color red into any hexagon shape i
don't think we ever went that far uh we
did kind of point when like
hexagons showed up in one of vision but
i don't think i ever went as far to say
like that means my pistol because the
number six is six six six i didn't do
the freaking q and on numerology but i
you know i get that we were kind of the
tip of the spear of the whole mephisto
movement and i do agree that we probably
earned the scorn when mapisto did not
show up in one division i get it but in
the months since every smartass on
twitter and reddit has turned mephisto
confirmed into such a meme that they
just refused to listen when the mcu had
started to make very real overt
references to mephisto's existence so i
honestly believe that the guys who are
still making mepisto jokes out there are
like the older dudes who clearly aren't
really paying attention to the mcu and
just want to look relevant like that
steve bashemy meme where he's like how
do you do fellow kids that's what you
look like when you make your fiscal
jokes uh and i get that it was a joke
for a long time and it's been pretty
funny but for for many of you it might
still be a joke and i guess it's okay
but we're not crying wolf anymore
mephisto is here this episode of
she-hulk wasn't even the first
clear reference to satan or the devil
existing in the mcu because thor eleven
thunder explicitly stated that the
winner of the most souls sacrificed in
the name of a god was quote satan zeus
actually says that in the movie that
plus acknowledging the existence of a
god of carpentry aka jesus christ
suggesting that this whole evil
christian counterpart would also
logically exist in this universe and now
madison and she-hulk says that she spent
time in a lava pit in a fire realm she
got out by making a pact with a talking
goat named jake jake made her sign a
contract we actually see this in the
closing credits art and if she ever
spoke out about that contract he would
claim her soul and the souls of those
she loves and then madison leaves this
realm within her hand a bloody beating
human heart and we further saw the
appearance of this fire realm during
this goblin bat sequence it's a rocky
fiery lava cavern similar to the lava
river dimension that we saw in doctor
strange the multiverse of madness which
we saw briefly during the montage but
then later american chavez chooses this
realm as where she wants to banish the
scarlet witch ii there was a deliberate
choice to revisit that realm in
particular now i get why the producers
of she-hulk held back from calling this
hell explicitly or calling jake mavisto
explicitly they are a goofy satirical
hangout disney plus series marvel
studios likely didn't want mepisto's
grand entrance to be right here but the
writers were probably given instructions
to have a drunken character like madison
give the goat a different name the art
depicts him wearing a name tag that says
jake suggesting that it was a name that
madison gave him and he just kind of
went with it also we know mobisto takes
all kinds of different forms and goes by
many many names
could there be another reason though
behind the name choice of jake
well i looked into it werewolf by night
marvel's halloween special which is
coming up it is going to be the next mcu
title in disney plus jack russell's
original name was jacob russoff jacob's
father gregor came from a bloodline of
lycanthropes when his 18th century
father grigory tried to slay a vlad
dracula gregor the 20th century
descendant finds the darkhold in the
darkhold he reads a passage that
reawakens the werewolf curse in his
family and that's how jacob russoff
becomes a werewolf once he turns 18 his
werewolf comes out uh and that name jake
could be setting up mephisto to appear
in werewolf by night with jack russell
that's just i don't know i i don't know
if that's the case jake could just be a
random name maybe they're like maybe
they're searching through pages of
comics okay my pistol is never called
jake so we'll choose that name and i'm
like
where are my night jake and they're like
goddamn it
but empty let's talk about what we think
the terms of madison's contract with
jake were why did she come out of hell
with a with a bloody heart in her hand
whose heart was that yeah i have no clue
whose heart that was that was kind of
creepy i hope madison didn't have to
kill someone uh but i
i have the sneaking suspicion and like i
hope this isn't true that madison
herself is is a type of plant planted
too long by whoever like mephisto
whoever it was that sent her there um i
think that like this this entity's
trying to mess with the sorcerer supreme
um directly by sending her directly to
his home because madison wanted to go
home like she didn't want to go see wong
she didn't know wong was really so uh i
think that um
whatever the contract was like
i think it was just mainly like get me
out of here i just want to go home and
this evil um nefarious entity is like
all right um if you're gonna go back to
the plane where i don't really hang out
let me cause some trouble because i want
to take over that plane or i don't know
whatever so he wants to do he wants to
directly affect the sort of supreme uh
but what do you think i think uh
i would love if that heart is the heart
of johnny blaze so we got the reference
to donnie blaze but what if the heart is
johnny blaze's heart that uh and like
jake was mephisto or some kind of
incarnation mephisto some piece of
mephisto uh so madison accidentally
stumbles into this fire realm
uh mephisto's like ooh delightful
someone i can use to do my bidding uh so
maybe he like uses uh like he sends her
back into the mortal realm with johnny
blaze's heart after it's been cursed
somehow or something like that or that
like he has to like reclaim his heart
from kamar taj they're gonna be some
tie-in with how we get ghost rider
johnny blaze in the mcu that is
connected to the fact that his heart is
now with the sorcerer's spring wong
because when you watch that scene the
heart just kind of sits there on the
shag rug which i think is just really
fun like who's this where's it gonna go
now and so we know for anyone who
doesn't really know the origin story of
ghost rider it is tied in with mephisto
like that's how ghostwriter has his
power of fire is it's the fires of
mephisto that he he has like this deal
with mephisto that's similar to the deal
that madison has now
would the fc go it's crazy it's make
madison the ghost rider of the mcu
[Laughter]
but
not the way we want to go i think i
think but madison does need to be in the
ghost writers show i think i think the
idea here is that madison is one of many
characters in the mcu who has made a
deal with the devil right and we're
going to see how lots of characters who
have made a deal with the devil through
some kind of accident through some kind
of wish fulfillment and it's all going
to tie in with the dark hole it's going
to tie in with the sorcerers and we're
starting to plant the seeds here uh i
don't know if madison's gonna come back
i sure hope she does because she's
delightful
and i got that covenant of chaos or in
wonder man because wonder man's gonna be
set in the world of hollywood show
business madison's gotta show up at a
party in the show right like oh yeah
madison like she needs to be the new
colson
yeah
oh for sure
for sure call center stan lee like the
madison that that yeah madison makes the
cameo i mean she's got to be at these
clubs dancing with zemo like i i assume
she was in madripore at some point at
these clubs oh yeah she's the best
just in addition to like a potential
people that this uh demon could be i
think that we could also be looking at
um a demon called the nameless one um
who doesn't have a name they only call
him the nameless one but he's also the
god or the leader of this group of um
demons called the undying ones if i'm
not mistaken and like we saw in this
episode that these demons that hulk
shield was punching we're just not dying
and i'm just thinking like hmm maybe we
could be dealing with um the undying one
here because the undying one sorry um
the nameless one because the the hulk
did have a brief interaction with the
name this one in the comics so um i'm
thinking either nameless one or maybe
even satanish but like mephisto is like
number one for me like that has to be
like a big guess here because like he's
too big he's literally the biggest most
associated name for satan in the mcu so
i'm feeling mephisto for sure i mean we
are recording this episode on wednesday
it's obviously you're watching it now
here on thursday and today's disney plus
day so we don't know if there's going to
be any announcements about werewolf by
night or what that show will look like
um but like it's not gonna be a show
it's gonna be a one-off special but like
i don't know halloween season dealing
with the jack russell a story that has
to do with the dark hold i feel like
mepista would be an interesting person
to bring into this show like it would be
a very high profile thing like what a
way to end phase four on disney plus
i guess we also have the guardians of
the galaxy holiday special and we'll
have black panther what kind of forever
coming in november but like if you if
you think like the star of phase four is
either like wong or wanda maximoff or
something like that i feel like
mepisto's been such a huge part of the
phase four speculation train like right
at the end here to bring in mephisto
would be
freaking amazing i feel like
it'd
it would make my year it would it would
fix everything
everything in my life it would be like
another um like miss marvel x-men mic
drop it's like oh yeah
got it and mephisto
please marvel if you're listening
there's still time there's still there's
still time do it please all right we
have a lot more questions coming out of
this episode of she-hulk but we want to
thank brooklyn and for sponsoring this
episode whether you're a superhuman hulk
or just a regular old human we all want
a comfortable night's sleep in the best
sheets possible but how do you determine
which sheets are the best with all those
confusing thread counts that don't even
matter well that's where brooklyn comes
in brooklyn was created to give
customers luxury hotel level home
essentials they offer everything from
snuggly sheets to cozy towels and robes
loungewear accessories and much more
they partner with top caliber suppliers
and they only use the highest grade
materials brooklyn knows better than
anyone that high quality materials are
the most important element of a good
sheet not really thread count because
each sheet is made with ultra durable
cotton that will get softer and softer
with every use and wash you'll feel like
you're snuggling up to breathable
supreme comfort every single night no
matter how you sleep and they offer a
top-tier 365-day return policy plus an
additional year for sheets pillowcases
and duvet covers and if you're new to
the brand and not sure where to start
rest easy and shop in comfort with
brooke lennon's online quiz whether
you're looking for the perfect set of
cozy cheats a new robe or a complete
home overhaul their quiz is the best
place to find a curated list of high
quality products that are perfectly
suited to your lifestyle so refresh your
rest today with brooklyn and best in
class betting go to brooklyn.com and use
the promo code inside marvel to get 20
off plus free shipping on your purchase
of 100 or more that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
and enter the promo code inside marvel
for 20 off plus free shipping on your
purchase today we also want to thank
bluetooth for sponsoring this episode
fellas we all want to perform a little
magic in the bedroom but sometimes you
need more than just a sling ring you
need a little blue that's right this
episode is also brought to you by
bluetooth confidence can take you far in
life it can also help in the bedroom
that's where blue chew comes in blue
chew is unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis put in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you can take them anytime day or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready for
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you receive your
prescription within days it's all done
online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package so if you
could benefit from some extra confidence
when it's time to perform bluetooth can
help and we've got a special deal for
our fans try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code marvel at checkout just
pay the five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code marvel to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
bluetooth for sponsoring this podcast
all right mt i know you have some
thoughts on this question this montage
of matcher dates that jen goes on
do we think at least one of these guys
might actually be trying to steal
she-hulk's blood specifically i'm
talking about todd the nerdier one who
calls her a specimen and brings up a
vibranium could pierce her skin yeah
absolutely i think that that was a
teaser for like the greater uh threat to
she-hulk in the show i think that this
weirdo is trying to find ways to to
pierce this woman's skin i don't know
why what possessed this man to think
that like hey let's let me talk about
like ways to stab you like that's i want
to want to know how to do that and i
definitely feel like he's linked to
those guys that um you know uh jumped
jennifer at the end of episode three and
um i i do have a feeling that um and i'm
gonna be diving into this in my sunday
video but i have a feeling that uh this
todd guy could actually be
the brother of the leader um a little
marvel villain called madman who is a
red hulk ver like he's a red he's not
the red hulk but he is a red-colored
hulk who is obsessed with bruce banner
and he's like oh my god like it should
have been me who got that um
dose of radiation like because i wanted
the funding and i think that um because
the show is all about family and like
we're dealing with the cousin of bruce
banner i think that the show is like
gonna be like all right let's do the
brother of the leader because like it's
the family members of our our main or
our original hulk and the leader and i'm
thinking that yeah this this weird guy
is phillip stearns like his todd name is
a farce and uh he's just like trying to
get
jen's blood so that he could become
madman but that's my weird theory
empty i love that theory i i think that
there definitely is something more to
this guy because i think this character
i've seen this character actor and stuff
before i was just re-watching the
newsroom he plays a role in that he's on
like the ac and digital team uh i he's
shown up in a bunch of other stuff and
like if you're just gonna give him like
a one second cameo in a montage i feel
like they'd give they get other actors
to do that as like most of the other
actors in this uh montage have like they
have small careers that are probably
going to get bigger after this good for
them but like this guy is like
he can do more than just the part that
he played here and i feel like he's
going to come back in a future episode i
think you're right i think he's going to
be part of the same effort that the
wrecking crew is part of he probably had
a needle in his backpack ready to pull
out and steal his blood
uh and he's like he's kind of like
probing here he's like what if vibranium
though or what if it was made of an
asgardian metal or something like that
like he's trying to figure it out so i
think we'll see this guy again
absolutely
dude
i think yeah just like we were talking
about last week there's some effort
there's someone there's some boss to the
wrecking crew whether it's the leader
whether it's kingpin whether it's val
there's some nefarious entity that is
trying to steal hulk blood uh and is
trying to replicate it in some way and
hopefully it leads to something like red
hulk i think that'd be really exciting
okay wong has an interesting line where
he references a higher legal power that
he serves and he references the book of
vashanti you know that was the book of
good spells that counteracted the dark
holds and uh multiverse of madness do we
think this is a reference to the living
tribunal yeah i think it's very likely a
reference to the living tribunal um it
just makes sense because like you know
we see the living tribunal in doctor
strange the multiverse madness because
we so we know that this is like an mcu
confirmed canon character and the living
tribunal
is essentially in charge of the
multiverse and like in charge of making
sure everything just makes it run
smoothly so it makes sense for the
living tribunal to be like that ultimate
authority for um for wong to answer to
but what do you think well yeah i think
uh you know we were talking about how
wong remembers the the memory wipe spell
from spiderman no way home and he
clearly remembers parts of it he might
not remember that peter parker was the
uh the subject of that spell
i i have a feeling that most people
still see peter parker as kind of a
stranger to them but um but i think the
fact that he remembered that the spell
was being conducted at all speaks to the
fact that the sorcerer's supreme is kind
of connected with these other cosmic
level entities i think he has like a
direct line and we know that the
sorcerers wield a weapon called the
staff at the living tribunal and i think
you know if the show is all about uh
licensing and uh and copyright
infringement i don't think the living
tribunal as like the legal authority
would allow them to use something called
the staff of the living tribunal with
unless he had some kind of uh uh
connection with them some kind of uh
they're under his legal jurisdiction in
a way it would be my thinking i just
think that the ancient one a sorcerer
supreme had some kind of divine insight
of what future events would be i think
the sorcerer's supreme that rank affords
you a certain kind of tier of access
that includes uh
communications with things like the
watcher the living tribunal and other
entities like that all right uh the last
question i want to ask you empty wong in
this post credits uh scene said that
they still have some like vodka and
yak's milk left over from the wedding
who got married at commerce and why
weren't we invited
exactly it sure wasn't uh doctor strange
and uh what's her name what's wrong with
my name christie yeah sure was like dr
stranger christine
that'll never happen i i wonder who it
was um
yeah i don't know like hopefully it was
a nice wedding well uh well it seemed
like wong had that uh girlfriend and
sarah but she died in the event she died
versus madness uh so maybe he was able
to resurrect her using some spell i want
to say rintra got married to someone it
got married rindra and another sorcerer
got married uh at commerce that's my
hope
i hope so because rental looks like he
uh he might struggle in the dating scene
as well
well rinsha is really great at sewing as
well like richard would make a great
domestic partner right exactly i would
date bridger if i was into green ox men
[Laughter]
you should be you should be into that
rintra i mean look you know
gender is a construct in t and it
doesn't matter oh rinchoy is just a
great partner and i would we'd all be
lucky to be with french we you know so
very kill let's do it rintra mephisto
or
or the dr arthur the too good to be true
doctor
well we gotta we gotta get rid of uh we
gotta get rid of arthur because uh he
was a jerk yeah kill kill arthur for
sure we marry rintra obviously you marry
your intro and then we we gotta bang
whoever's left who was it again yeah you
[ __ ] fisto
i mean to me that's like a bad deal
you just spend a night with me fist are
you kidding me are you kidding me
hell yeah it's gonna be the best night
of your life he's gonna tear his face
the things you're gonna see the feelings
you're gonna feel
the contracts you're gonna sign
oh yeah absolutely yeah but he's gonna
take out your heart at the end and give
it to madison and madison's gonna break
yeah that's uh extreme bdsm right there
we'll leave it there for this episode of
inside marvel again jess's breakdown of
all the easter eggs in this episode is
going to come out later today so stick
around be sure to check that out you can
follow mt and mastertainment you can
follow me at eavos and follow new
rockstars on all social media
subscribing new rockstars or breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye-bye everyone
[Music]
you